التطورات الاخيره ازدهار تتعلق بدوي
صافرات الانذار تحديدا في مدينه ايلات
جنوب اسرائيل على البحر الاحمر وهذه المره
تم بحسب الاذاعه العبريه ووسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اخرى رصد اعتراض لجسم جوي لم
تحدد طبيعته بعد في منطقه خليج ايلات
وبالتالي هذه هي المره الاولى بعد قرابه
شهر ونصف لم تدوي فيها صافرات
الانذار في هذه المدينه التي تعرضت مع
بدايه الحرب على غزه اكثر من مره
الاستهدافات سواء كان بالقذائف او
الصواريخ البالستيه ايضا وكذلك مسيرات
اطلقت من عده مواقع تحديدا اطلقها
الحوثيون في اليمن وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قد اعلن في ديسمبر الماضي ان منظومات
الدفاعات الجويه كانت قد اعترضت اكثر من
مره صواريخ مجنحه وموجهه وصواريخ باليستيه
بعيده المدى في المجال الجوي كانت في
طريقها لاستهداف هذه ال المدينه شهود عيان
في مدينه ايلات يتحدثون عن سماع دوي
انفجارات اكثر من انفجار لكن وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اعتراض لجسم
مشبوه ولم تحدد طبيعته بعد ولكن يبدو بان
صافرات الانذار دوت الانطلاق ايه ال
القذائف التي اطلقتها منظومات الدفاعات
الجويه لكن نذكر انه بعد ان بدا الحوثيون
باستهداف هذه المدينه تحديدا من اليمن عزز
الجيش الاسرائيلي من منظومات الدفاعات
الجويه في مدينه ايلات وفي محيط مدينه
ايلات اي سواء كان منظومه القبه الحديديه
ولكن ايضا منظومه اورو حيتس وهي لاعتراض
الصواريخ البالستيه بعيده المدى من
الجيلين الاول والثاني وهي اي منظومه
متطوره باستطاعتها اعتراض صواريخ بعيده
المدى في مجالات جويه مختلفه وبالتالي
هناك حاله تاهب ايضا على مستوى ال
الدفاعات الجويه وعلى مستوى استعدادات
الجيش ايضا للتعامل مع هذه الجبهه لكن
نذكر انه منذ قرابه شهر ونصف لم تدوي
صافرات الانذار في هذه المدينه تحديدا ولم
يتم استهدافها كما حدث في الاشهر الاخيره
الماضيه مع بدايه الحرب على غزه في حينه
كان هناك قلق اسرائيلي واضح من ان يفتح في
هذه المدينه تحديدا جبهه جديده واستهدافها
طيله الوقت من جانب الحوثيين في اليمن